I think that you should call on
speakerphone every single person who's
no longer subscribed and once was for
three months I think you should
videotape the interaction of you saying
thank you not try to sell them to re-up
but just to build a relationship around
the content the reason you should do it
is market research I'm adding content
creation and reactivation of business so
calling literally calling and saying I
just we just want to thank you for ever
being on our service hopefully it
brought you some value obviously aware
that you're no longer using us but I
hope it sprung you into a better you
thank you the most fun part of the phone
call is when you're done just doing love
and good and there's this awkward three
second pause because they're waiting for
you to give them an offer to reactivate
but you don't I think the market
research you'll get to why people
unsubscribed like by the 19th call if
they all said the berries were the
problem you're like oh [ __ ] should we
even have berries like like it's real
market research